على كلن ينضم الينا من القاهره المخرج
رؤوف عبد العزيز سيد رؤوف اهلا بك معنا
مبروك لكم نجاح فيلم الباب الاخضر وحدثنا
عن الاسباب التي قادت الى هذا النجاح
مبسوط اكيد برده اني ردود الافعال الكبيره
اللي جاءت لي على باب الاخضر
والحمد لله
ايش الاسباب التي نجاح وتحقيق هذا النجاح
اكيد رقم واحد الاستاذ اسامه
نص بالكامل من من تاليف الاستاذ اسامه
سيناريو وحوار وطبعا قصه
اكيد السر الاول في النجاح وبعد كده
الاجتهاد الحمد لله اللي قام به فريق
العمل بالكامل واللي بشكر كل الناس اللي
ساعدوني في التجربه دي سواء وضع الكاميرا
او قدام الكاميرا بصراحه
استاذ رؤوف الباب الاخضر اللي اعتمد على
كتابه سيناريو قبل 30 عاما عم نحكي عن
الراحه لاسامه انور عكاشه هل كان اسهل
اخراجيا بالنسبه لكم ام هناك صعوبه بفهم
ما كان يدور في راس الكاتب والسيناريست
قبل 30 عاما
اكيد تجربه صعبه جدا
[موسيقى]
بس في نفس الوقت
الاستاذ اسامه طريقه الكتابه عنده والسرد
حقيقي واضحه جدا طبعا الطلعه اا على كل
النسخ الاستاذ اسامه قام بتعديلها
وتظبيط حاجات مختلفه من وقت ثاني لان هو
كتب الفيلم على فترات مختلفه
وقام بالتعديله اكثر من مره همم طبعا ده
غير عيش الكبير همم اللي فن الاستاذ اسامه
صغير باحب اعماله سواء
مهنه الاخراج بادرس اعماله سواء لما جيت
كمان همم اعمل باب الاخضر عملت عمليه بحث
كبير الاستاذ اسامه في همم في في افكار
وفي الطرق اللي دائما بيحب بيقدم بها
شخصياته يعني كنت عامل شبه دراسه كبيره
يعني
رؤوف يعني الفيلم يهدي يحكي بطريقه
تشويقيه احداث تخيليه الى اي مدى كان هذا
التحدي بالنسبه لكم كمخرج
التحدي الاكبر همم ان انا لقيت جوه الفيلم
بالرغم اني بتدور يعني احداث من 30 سنه
فاتت همم لكن كان في تحدي كبير بالنسبه لي
وشغف كمان ان الاقي ان الاستاذ اسامه قادر
يتوقع اللي احنا بنمر به دلوقت وان هو
شايف اللي احنا فيه دلوقت همم كان شايفه
من 30 سنه وبيتكلم عنه همم فكره السيطره
على العقول او فكره ان الحرب الجديده في
العالم
هتواجهها الهويه المصريه
همم ده كان وقتها يعتبر حاجه من 30 سنه مش
موجوده همم
رؤوف يعني انت الان تتفق معه يعني لو كان
الراحل اسامه عكاشه حيا مثلا اليوم
وتريدون ان تتفقوا تخططوا لي اخراج هذا
الفيلم هل في نقاط ممكن قد تختلف معها في
مطرحه في السابق
صدقيني حقيقي لا سواء انا
وسواء كل اللي شاركوا في العمل
الاساتذه
الممثلين اللي شاركوني واللي انا بشكرهم
جدا جدا جدا على صوم من النجم همم النصار
همم
كل همم
يعني شركاء معي وراء الكاميرا من مهندس
الديكور للموسيقى
للمدارس همم كلنا حقيقي همم كنافه جدا مع
الاستاذ اسامه ومش هيكون عايزين نغير اي
حاجه
اها الطبيعي استاذ رؤوف في ناس بقولوا لك
انه كثير في سوداويه بالفيلم والناس سمت
تشوف مشاهد حزن وهمم وسواد
اسامه زي او معظمها كان في بعض الحاجات
طبعا المختلفه الثانيه لكن كان معظمها زي
زي ارابيسك او قريب بيضه الاستاذ اسامه
كان دائما مهموم جدا بفكره
الحفاظ على الهويه المصريه
وعدم سحاق الشخصيه المصريه من المواطن همم
والباب الاخضر همم بيندري تحت نفس السلسله
دي من التوجهات اللي عند الاستاذ اسامه